The technology of warfare is in constant flux.
I mean, there weren’t even drones as we
know them until late in the last century,
and now?
RELEASE THE SWARM.
Hey there friends, Trace here for DNews.
Military technology has been a driver of innovation
for centuries.
Scientists, keen to see their research funded,
have been recruited into government programs
and helped create some truly fearsome technology.
In the last few weeks, we’ve seen a number
of pieces of military tech that have given
us the shudders…
For example, in January 2017, the Pentagon
announced they’d successfully launched 103
microdrones from F/A-18 Super Hornet fighter
jets.
A DRONE SWARM!
In fact, according to the Pentagon’s statement,
the 103 microdrones are very much like a Zerg
swarm.
They’re, quote, “not preprogrammed synchronized
individuals, they are a collective organism,
sharing one distributed brain for decision-making
and adapting to each other like swarms in
nature.”
End quote.
Let all those who oppose the Overmind feel
the wrath of the swarm!
The modern unmanned aerial drone was first
imagined by Nikola Tesla in the 1890s.
Now more than 100 years later, we’ve created
a hydra-like swarm of six inch (16cm) autonomous
vehicles that could (according to Popular
Mechanics) jam enemy communications, form
an ad-hoc communications network, carry explosives,
trick or jam enemy radar, and even attack
individuals.
The terrifying goal is to create the drones
in batches of 1,000 and be able to launch
them from fighter jets or large cargo planes.
Of course, in this crazypants future we’d
also need a way to fight drones… so why
not lasers?
IT’S THE FUTURE, RIGHT?
In December 2016, the Department of Defense
announced a 51-percent budget increase (to
328 million dollars) for “directed energy”
weapons...
Fancy budget talk for LASERS.
The DoD’s research group, DARPA, has been
working on laser weapons for a long time.
They tried mounting lasers inside 747s, but
they were relatively slow, and not particularly
accurate.
The Navy mounted a laser on the USS Ponce,
which uses heat energy to destroy drones and
other targets, the Army has a laser on the
back of a truck that can attack drones and
mortars, and the Marines are working on a
humvee mounted laser of their very own.
Of course, this new research is still classified,
but with such a sharp budget increase, there
must be something going on.
Lasers are still bulky energy hogs, but in
an email to Seeker’s own Eric Niller: the
director of the Directed Energy Professional
Society said the biggest issue is just getting
the military to actually use lasers.
I mean, if we can shoot a drone with a bullet
or other traditional projectile, why use a
laser?
There is one obvious reason, pollution.
Lasers are energy, but a bullet leaves behind
a casing, and the lead from the projectile
itself.
And it’s not just bullets, shell casings
from grenades and explosives also are left
in warzones.
Over time, the lead from the bullets themselves
can pollute ground water and poison the soil.
Once in the environment, lead causes damage
to the “brain, blood, kidneys, heart, and
reproductive organs” and can kill wildlife
too.
Even though it sounds hippy dippy, the DoD
has a solution: biodegradable, lead-free bullets!
Sadly, not the actual small bullets, just
40 and 120 millimeter sized casings to start
-- they’re used in mortars and tanks.
The U.S. Army Corps of Engineers has developed
and tested bioengineered seeds that can be
embedded in the shells, that grow plants after
they’ve been left in soil for “several
months.”
Those plants then absorb chemicals and contribute
to the rehabilitation of the warzone.
Yep, the U.S. Army could shoot shells that
result in new forests.
Warfare of tomorrow might not be Terminators
and Matrices.
Instead, we might be shooting lasers, at swarms
of unmanned aerial drones, and if we do have
to fire a round, it might leave behind the
seed of a new life.
The future is weird.
One thing is for sure, scientists will keep
working on projects that push humanity forward,
and sometimes, it will be thanks to war.
For example, Ex-Nazis and Jewish scientists
were responsible for getting us to the moon.
Amy’s got the story for you here.
How do you feel about these?
Do you have a favorite?
Tell us in the comments, please subscribe
for more DNews and thanks for watching.